[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia enfocó su cita con
la actualidad francesa por las pantallas
de France 24 este verano los franceses
se han enfrentado cara a cara con el
cambio climático olas de calor sequía
incendios forestales e incluso una
tormenta con víctimas mortales en la
isla de córcega el gobierno ha hecho del
tema una prioridad en este regreso de
vacaciones y ya no se habla tanto de
hacer frente al cambio climático sino
más bien de adaptarse
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el segundo verano más caliente de su
historia es el que acaban de pasar los
franceses según los datos de metemos el
organismo encargado de la meteorología
en este país sin embargo los periodos
festivales de los próximos 20 años serán
aún más cálidos
un río seco en el departamento delgaj
tierra resquebrajada en la loira
atlántica cultivos quemados e incendios
gigantes en el suroeste
Francia ha sido golpeada por el segundo
verano más caliente de su historia en
promedio hizo 2,3 grados más que lo
normal en este mapa se aprecian los
récords de calor batidos Incluso en
ciudades con temperaturas moderadas
39,3 en Best 41 grados en el puerto
bretón de Sant nacea 43 en la Bahía de
arcasón en el sur 38 grados en limosere
en el centro del país o 38,8 en chamberí
al pie de los alpes picos de calor
impresionantes pero sobre todo olas de
calor de una duración inédita 33 días
Este verano la consecuencia una sequía
más violenta y extensa que la de 1976 o
el 2003 pues falta la lluvia 85% menos
de precipitaciones en julio y menos 30%
en agosto para los científicos este
balance de verano confirma el cambio
climático y la desaparición progresiva
de las cuatro estaciones
que son la cuestión no es saber si vamos
a tener 52 grados en Francia sino cuando
además se prolonga el periodo estival
con inviernos menos fríos y menos largos
y veranos más largos y más calientes y
las estaciones intermedias se reducen
según los expertos de la ONU el cambio
climático expone a Francia a cuatro
riesgos mayores calor falta de agua
perdidas agrícolas e inundaciones el
verano 2022 confirma estas perspectivas
cinco personas murieron este verano en
la isla de córcega por una tormenta que
meteofón no pudo prever pero la isla
tiene otros problemas como la sequía las
soluciones de algunos alcaldes sin
embargo no son del gusto de la mayoría
la vegetación cruje bajo sus pies
normalmente Las ovejas de Pascal comen
en este campo en tomino córcega pero
este año es imposible todo está seco
Hace seis años que yo exploto este campo
y es la primera vez que está así en este
estado
si falta pasto tiene que comprar maíz
cieno para sus animales lo que cuesta
dinero
será cada vez más duro porque los
precios de los alimentos aumentan cada
mes y si mañana no tenemos ni siquiera
agua para darles no sé qué vamos a hacer
aquí en julio cayó un 30% menos de
lluvia que lo normal toda la comunidad
Busca agua
fuera insumos Esta es una de las fuentes
de alimentación de la ciudad normalmente
siempre estaba llena pero como ustedes
pueden ver no hay una gota
el alcalde prohibió llenar piscinas o
lavar el auto una medida fuerte pero
insuficiente
A mediados de Julio también realizaron
una perforación en urgencia
nos permite sacar agua de entre 65 y 85
metros de profundidad es una bomba
pero la sequía persiste entonces hay que
ir más lejos la comuna de tomino y su
vecina rogliano Serán las primeras en
córcega en tener una fábrica para
desalinizar el agua una tecnología que
se usa ya en Isla Juan en Bretaña pero
la instalación cuesta dinero casi un
millón de euros y en córcega el impacto
sobre el medio ambiente no contenta a
todos
son soluciones claras que consumen
energía y que contaminan de 100 litros
de agua solamente 40 servirán a la
alimentación y al agua potable y el
resto en forma de salmuera un agua muy
salada serán nuevamente lanzados al
medio ambiente
la fábrica de desalinización del Cabo
córcega debiera estar funcionando A
mediados de este mes
pero adaptarse al cambio climático
requiere creatividad como la que tiene
el alcalde de un pequeño pueblo francés
una iglesia a la moda con su techo lleno
de paneles solares a este pueblo de 400
habitantes parece gustarle La idea
es una buena idea porque hoy hablamos de
Ecología de tecnología verde
le da color y alguien que no sabe va a
seguir su camino sin darse cuenta
la idea es del alcalde renovar el techo
de la iglesia en mal estado era un gran
costo financiero para la comuna entonces
Olivier Daniel decidió reemplazar las
Tejas por paneles solares
el objetivo era restaurar el patrimonio
rural y que nos costara lo menos posible
la electricidad que producen los paneles
se vende lo que sirve para cubrir tres
cuartas partes de la mensualidad del
préstamo utilizado para realizar los
trabajos
el objetivo es conseguir 8 o 9000 euros
de ganancias al año lo que nos permitirá
reembolsar solo 3600 euros en vez de
12.500
el resultado una iglesia restaurada sin
tener que Aumentar los impuestos en la
comuna una idea que cuenta con la
bendición del cura
da tranquilidad saber que tenemos un
techo bonito y que podemos celebrar a
Dios en un lugar limpio en el sentido
ecológico del término
un proyecto que el cura defiende en
otras Iglesias donde el oficio y donde
los paneles solares no son del gusto de
todo el mundo
está bien debería haber más
al comienzo eso molesto a la población
no rural
si se explica la utilidad y la razón la
gente lo entiende y lo acepta
en Francia cada vez más comunes buscan
soluciones para mantener un patrimonio
muy costoso una de las consecuencias del
cambio climático es el aumento del nivel
de los océanos Esto está afectando sobre
todo a la costa atlántica francesa sin
embargo hay quienes siguen empecinados
en comprarse una propiedad frente al mar
cuando el mar escarba bajo la tierra la
erosión hace más pequeña la playa y las
viviendas se ven amenazadas sin embargo
estas propiedades son muy demandadas y
sus precios aumentan como aquí en la
canau en la costa atlántica de Francia
esta inversionista compró ya cuatro
departamentos algunos metros del océano
tengo uno en esta residencia y otras
tres allá
su última adquisición es este
departamento de 180 mil euros se
reembolsará mucho antes que el riesgo de
inundación Marina de aquí a 50 años
si hoy dijera que el riesgo es de 7 u 8
años estoy de acuerdo no sería muy
juicioso incluso sería inconsciente
invertir pero el riesgo de sobre un
patrimonio que está completamente
financiado
comprar para invertir pero también para
pasar sus vacaciones a esta gente
inmobiliaria le lleven las demandas como
por este departamento
se encuentra en esta residencia justo
allí tenemos vista al océano la oferta
de venta uno está publicada
pero he dicho ya tiene demandas de
potenciales compradores incluso sin
visita
si esto le conviene lo veremos juntos
tenemos el lápiz en la mano de acuerdo
la demanda ha hecho duplicarse los
precios en primera línea de
marzo este por ejemplo en el 2019 se
vendía a 70 mil euros de memoria
hoy 120.000 euros todo va muy rápido
el mar debería retroceder 30 metros de
aquí a 2040 y 120 metros de aquí a 2100
como consecuencia la comuna tiene
planeado relocalizar una parte del
frente marítimo 1200 hogares y 110
comercios podrían ser desplazados
los agentes inmobiliarios deben advertir
en cada visita a sus clientes de los
riesgos que están tomando
aquí no estamos en Zona Roja pero esta
puede agrandarse y este edificio podría
caer en la Zona Roja dentro de algunos
años
una vez en Zona Roja este edificio puede
ser demolido pero eso no desanima esta
Clienta que está lista para ser una
oferta
desde que soy niña Vengo al Atlántico ya
sea la costa vasca en la Bahía de
arcachón o aquí y siempre he soñado con
tener un departamento en primera línea
estoy dispuesta a tomar el riesgo
absolutamente
en Francia más de 100 comunas podrían
evacuar su frente marítimo para escapar
al aumento del nivel de las aguas del
mar
la mostaza es uno de los ingredientes
Estrellas de la cocina francesa sin
embargo se produce con semillas
importadas desde Canadá lo que la ha
vuelto muy vulnerable a la sequía no ha
desaparecido totalmente de las
estanterías la mostaza que los últimos
días se ha vuelto un objeto muy
codiciado llena las repisas de este
negocio parisino vimos clientes que
venían solo para comprar mostaza y luego
partir solo con un artículo
una producción local en senemana hace 30
años que Patrick cultiva el grano en la
tierra de sus ancestros y la cosecha de
Julio ha sido abundante aquí estamos
sobre la cultura cosecha 2023 porque
sembramos hace algunos días en este
campo de 18 hectáreas cinco están
dedicadas a la mostaza gracias a su
mostaza artesanal producida en la
periferia de París el empresario no
conoce la crisis la escasez de granos
canadienses le ha permitido triplicar
sus ganancias este ex jefa de cocina
también está beneficiándose de la
coyuntura hace tres años que se
reconvirtió en la producción de mostaza
en su taller en el sur de Francia el
molino trabaja a tiempo completo
casi tres turnos por día de seis a nueve
horas de trabajo en promedio desde el
año pasado su producción se ha
triplicado una tonelada de mostaza por
mes consigue los granos en uno de los
raros productores del departamento que
privilegia a las empresas locales
todos los productores de mostaza de
occitania son prioritarios porque
tenemos una asociación mantenemos
estables las tarifas y evitamos la
especulación el inconveniente es para el
cliente estas mostazas artesanales son
cinco veces más caras que su equivalente
de origen industrial
y hasta aquí este capítulo de Francia
enfoco Muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado y hasta una próxima por las
pantallas de France 24 o en Francia
24.com